ok that's a good introduction to indexes
but there is more and in this section we
will cover composite indexes remember
the single property index we looked at
the head the city as the value a single
property index is also called a built-in
index data store can in many cases
combined results from different built-in
indexes to provide a response to a query
but there are cases where this is not
possible that's when we need a composite
index in fact we have already used
composite indexes in conference central
for this query retrieve all conferences
filter by City and topic and sort by
name this is a composite index because
the built-in indexes for City topic and
name cannot be combined to generate the
result for this to work an index table
consisting of multiple values in
combination must be created this is
exactly what a composite index is so how
our composite index is built there are
two different ways the first way is to
add the index to an index file App
Engine dust is a little bit differently
depending on which languages use so you
will see how to do this in one of the
exercises the other way is to actually
run your application locally on your
development server in this case if App
Engine encounters a query that requires
the composite index it will
automatically update the index file when
you later deploy to App Engine this
index file will be uploaded as well so
it will also exist when executing on App
Engine all right it's time for an
exercise where you will explore
composite indexes